voici d'ailleurs cette image les deux
concorde opération qui a duré 13 corps
de puisse être mis en service sur les
lignes commerciales et bien pour
symboliser cette coopération on avait
essayé de synchroniser tout ce décollage
malheureusement il ya eu un petit peu
d'avancé en angleterre mais les
commandants de bord était en liaison
radio ils ont pu rectifier le tir dirons
nous et vous voyez maintenant donc les
deux concorde qui décolle exact qui lève
le même
vous
l'accord doit encore nommer de france
mise sur le territoire de l'atlantique
et il tiendra la salle grèce
supersonique
il commencera par passer un peu après la
verticale de nantes
mach 1 et environ 20 minutes plus tard
atteindra mc2a latitude à l'altitude de
14 14 km les vitesses sont inscrits sur
ce cadran vous voyez devant nous sur les
cristaux liquides
car les passagers en fait ne
s'aperçoivent pas tellement qu'il passe
le mur 1900 personnes absolument pas
garanti j'ai volé sur concorde et le
passage du mur du champ est absolument
intercepté du reste voici l'annoncé qui
a été faite aux 100 passagers
aujourd'hui lorsque le mur du son a été
franchi
pas
je
m
et à moins mais mieux
non